a rising number of new neighborhoods are
being built around farms these suburban
housing developments are called Agri
hoods neighbors can work on fully
functional farms and bring fresh produce
home the trend is spreading across the
country there are Agra hoods in more
than two dozen states chip Reid is at
one of the largest in Ashburn Virginia
chip good morning
well good morning it's a beautiful day
in the Agra hood yes it's raining but if
you live in a community that has a farm
right in the middle of it you learn very
quickly that rain is a good thing that's
how you get beautiful cucumbers and
flowers and tomatoes like these all of
it grown right here on the community
farm it might look like work but for
these kids picking bushels of
blackberries and ripe tomatoes this is
the elbow right here put your thumb
there and snap that up is the perfect
way to spend a summer day on the farm
with strange creatures and surprises
their harvest soon becomes lunch
awesome cucumber and tomato salad
that's what Bonnie Moore loves to hear
tastes good as the culinary director at
willows furred farm she's introducing
the kids to this one right in their
backyard with 300 acres of working
farmland and 2,000 acres left for
conservation it's one of the largest
Agri heads in the country and it's part
of a rising trend in housing with over
200 Agri hoods across the nation from
Dallas Texas to outside of Atlanta
Georgia even inner city Detroit and
Southern California
they're bringing families back to a more
rural life why do you think this is a
booming idea for how to live
I think parents want to know what their
kids are eating and they want their kids
to be able to identify with food they're
not just identifying their food why does
it feel good to eat cucumbers that you
grew instead of buying them at the store
they're owning it so when you look at
this sound what do you think and it's
not just about growing veggies they're
also managing the land and no lawnmower
is as much fun as a herd of goats to the
kids
Deborah DRAM B is farmer Deb and expert
on goats healthy eating and the
importance of getting outside in nature
so how important is it to get kids out
here instead of in their houses doing
whatever they do on their devices well
gosh remember when you were out of
school because you spent the summer
working on a farm right and instead of
being inside on a device playing a video
game about farming or you know whatever
exists they can actually come and do it
for the goats to do their job kids have
to do their making sure they have plenty
of fresh water do you like doing this
work you do why because you're doing it
for the goats
unlike veggies goats give back it gets a
hug animal sins you get to take care of
them and that's really satisfying who
here loves working with goats who here
could see being a farmer someday this
could have been a golf course but it's
not it's fun it's way better why is it
better it's so much more interactive
they want their families to be able to
identify with something that's real real
food a real fun Melissa Miller says her
children love to be off the phones and
video games and on the farm it's just so
exciting they're seen where their food
is coming from and they're having a
healthier lifestyle because of it and I
think they'll agree it's it's so fresh
blueberries tastes better when you pick
them yourself this is literally farm to
table it is farm of the table just the
peaceful nature
we all have stressful lives with work
and families and friends but still just
to drive down the street you kind of
have your moment wait like the TV show
Green Acres but a little bit of
so on a summer morning when it's raining
what are most kids doing they're
sleeping late they're watching TV or on
their on their numerous electronic
devices your parents tell me that you'd
rather be out here organizing the
Community Farm market than being home in
bed or watching TV are they right
they really are okay well there you have
it straight from the farmers mouths Vlad
back to you that is a great story and
it's so great to see kids out there
enjoying the sunshine learning how to
farm can't beat that
looks like chip had fun too he did have
fun chip thank you